OK.
Lastly, again, questions related to Corona
virus and so on and so forth.
David, Donald Trump has been utterly incompetent
in dealing with Corona virus.
Can there be emergency removal of Trump for
failing to deal with coronavirus?
Listen, the emergency removal of Trump for
failing to deal with coronavirus is voting
in seven and a half months.
That's.
That's it.
Okay.
If the idea again, we said it would the Mueller
probe, we said it with impeachment.
We're not going to remove Trump with impeachment.
We're not going to remove Trump with an indictment.
We are not going to remove Trump with the
25th Amendment.
It's seven and a half months until the presidential
election is scheduled to take place.
I don't know what could be done.
Hypothetically about saying Trump's.
Trump has perpetuated the spread of a pandemic
when we could have been controlling it since
a month ago, three weeks ago.
I get it.
It's incompetence, it's dishonesty.
It's all of those things.
But the way to remove the guy is to vote him
out in November.
That it plain and simple and then actually
get adults in place, get a president in who
would never say something like, I know more
than the doctors.
I don't care what the doctors say.
I don't care what the scientists say.
I don't I don't care what other countries
say.
I know more than the doctors.
The doctors are regularly stunned by how much
I know about this.
That's weaponized, malignant narcissism.
We've got to get it out.
And I think we are all you know, instead of
focusing on it, could we emergency remove
Trump because it's not going to happen.
Let's focus on take control ourselves of making
sure that we aren't doing anything that could
spread the contagion.
That means staying home, working from home,
not hoarding supplies that caused people to
have to drive around even more, looking for
a roll of toilet paper.
Let's all work together.
And if we do that and it's a big if because
we seem to be failing in many ways.
If we do that, we can hopefully turn around
what are very, very concerning numbers coming
out in terms of new cases.
That would be my approach, as I've been saying
for years.
In November, we can remove Trump between now
and then.
Let's behave correctly.
Let's do the right things.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Packman dot com or by becoming
a patron at Patry on dot com slash.
David excuse me.
Slash David Packager.
David Packman Show David Packman Dot.com.